welcome to this video playing a vandal
Barbosa from Brazil and I'm desperately
looking for a finish to my bad run of
blitz games yeah this does not start
yeah nollie the bandoneon opening that
usually is totally misplaced miss plate
by black players and but also an opening
where you notoriously tend to lose games
because it is it is tricky yeah this
already begins like like us to tweak
strange things here that's really not a
good setup at all I'm close to being
able to exchange the dark squared bishop
yeah okay
okay I'm going for this simple standard
attack it's it's it's a bit early here
but it's probably still dangerous should
I take or Bishop g5 for us not so easy
to say you will play III anyway I guess
to distract me yeah okay I probably need
to take it it's still dangerous for
black I believe you cannot take twice on
d5 I think and then only three because
of the capture on g6 at the end get what
what's idea now is just to play Bishop
g5 again for the pin what to take c5
okay this this is a nice trick actually
going for for Bishop before yeah this is
a good defense he can take on d5 now
with DF DF night yeah this is also
possible of course
let you go g5 oh yeah maybe here try to
use the the pressure on the f file 94
this is what I was getting at but maybe
with this one this Queen f7 may tell
this is the idea behind that you know we
can just move the light yeah this is
probably the reason why my player sir is
not too great you can just keep this
night i mean i'm i'm i'm a piece down at
the moment
I don't understand anything here I can
just take it also okay then then he can
take a form I don't know why why not
night c 2 but of that the moment i'm i'm
calculating such utter nonsense that i
don't really know what to assess those
moves I'll get this piece back okay d 6
intending Bishop c4 he ignores it
strangely enough I am threatening to
take on on g6 as well but yes King evade
and then it's a it's a double attack
okay then I need to take and continue
from here I still have the deep on
this is threatening 95 and she does not
have a good way to stop both the deep on
and protect f7 the oddest I just take
here and I don't know is this just just
winning now for me yeah I've got a bad
game a really bad game by both players
ready let's see can I kind of promote
can I promote the porn somehow he's got
kick wicking of am ok I'll probably
should just take the airport this is the
easiest way to go yeah this was really a
bad game
it was probably completely winning yeah
my opening i mean fo was probably still
okay but II five and all this this was
too too quick I mean blacks black setup
is so bad that it can be refuted but not
the way I played and now it's not moving
anymore now we actually did he did move
okay yeah okay come on take the power
yeah this is fortunately very easy
winning now black resigned ah well I'm
going from bad to worse IAM i think that
the setup with Bishop d7 night before is
just unplayable against this against
this wide set up why does just getting
far too much play in the in the center
and yeah okay this is just one way to go
a six and the question is what to do now
yeah this is this is not the best I can
just go here computers on plus two plus
two in a position that is materially
equal this gives you some idea how bad
it is yeah this is just a completely
completely bad i mean White's idea is
just to double on the F file yeah this
is just plain lost it's just lost
because you have no squares for the
night this is bad yeah i played this
typically 5 f-5 motif is very typical
but it's not necessary here five it's
just just much better and compare
and here he's got this III you counter
plane now this is very very annoying
here I thought you would just play this
move but I have had this one okay so
this was okay I guess take stakes yeah
this is now Turkey I believe that black
shirt should have a win here didn't I
didn't see a concrete win but the
computer just wants to take a fall with
some edge from black but not a win and
this is just very strange move I thought
just here okay i get f 6 beggar maybe it
is not so clear I was really
disappointed that i was in destruction
and I didn't really I hadn't really
refuted this play how King just have no
is so much better winning yeah I have no
good square for the Roku this is worse
yeah now i'm somewhat back in the game
and now i'm even better much better be
success just bad yeah this is this whole
game reserve collection of of mistakes
by both sides with it yeah no I'm
winning again yeah this this ef5 is just
very strong and I don't really need to
play if I'm if I thus giving them
encounter play with the upon just a bad
decision i played this this too quickly
you five here three seconds it's a very
typical move but it's it's not well time
to him f5 is just much better okay
thanks for watching